the whole point of brexit for many
people was to get off this economy that
is producing too many graduates when
there aren't enough graduate jobs about
a third of graduates aren't working in
graduate jobs because there were too
many graduates we need fewer
universities and we need to get more
kids doing trades you're going to
technical colleges becoming doctors by
the way because we don't allow enough of
them to become doctors or to become
medical professionals and what the
government's done is said no actually
we're going to keep this broken model
going by allowing even more
International students into the country
in order to keep broken universities
afloat which therefore removes any
incentive for universities to invest in
you know building relationships with
community colleges and and helping
apprentices and all the rest of it and
so on all the tough decisions that the
conservatives should have taken all the
difficult choices they went for the easy
option so they can't solve the migration
question they don't want to solve the
migration question